there are a few games that have earned
the reverence that mass effect has
with the legendary edition and a brand
new game on the horizon
we decided to go back to where it all
began and take a look at the history of
mass effect
if you're a fan make sure to like this
video and subscribe for more mass effect
videos cause we've got a lot of them on
the channel
and more are coming
[Music]
mass effect developer bioware was
founded in 1995.
the infamous tidbit about its beginnings
was that three of its co-founders were
actually medical doctors who loved
gaming
and would create small simulation games
on the side
the team cut their teeth on a handful of
successful role-playing games including
baldur's gate and never winter nights
but it wasn't until a partnership with
lucasarts in the early aughts that they
would finally get to work on their opus
star wars knights of the old republic a
star wars game where you could create
your own character command your own
spaceship
explore iconic planets and assemble your
team
throughout the main quest players were
able to make decisions which affected
the ending of their game
it was through this that project
director casey hudson was able to lay
the framework
for what the team was calling sfx in
september 2003 hudson sat down for lunch
with the doctors
and didn't just pitch one game but three
he envisioned an ambitious trilogy where
your character actions and choices
are carried over from one game to the
next as the story goes
one of the doctors still remembers
burning his tongue on hot soup
during hudson's bold pitch the ambition
didn't end there either
hudson wanted to make a game that
spanned an entire galaxy
with a fast-paced combat system that
would rival third person action games
the game would be developed by the same
team that created knights of the old
republic
hudson imagined a game where players
could freely explore planets in an
online component that
by today's standards sounds awfully
similar to destiny or division
the original pitch document mentions
virtual environments where you can meet
other players and trade items with them
in a dynamic in-game economy while the
online component didn't quite make the
cut the doctors gave hudson the green
light for the project
and pre-production began the team spent
the first year putting the building
blocks in place for this
massive universe hudson and art director
derek watts wanted to create a vision of
the future that was clean
and slick a universe where form was just
as important as style
hudson felt that at the time most
science fiction was dark and gritty
and that mass effect could touch on a
style of science fiction that hadn't yet
been tapped in
games drawing inspiration from
futuristic art of the 70s and 80s and
films like red planet and solaris
project sfx soon became mass effect
[Music]
most of us loved the sleek environments
and the gameplay
but the exploration was a little more
divisive the maker was your way of
exploring the dozens of well
rather bland and kind of empty optional
worlds that mass effect had to offer
there was a red planet a green planet a
blue planet a white one
and even a couple of other colours if
you were lucky you'd come across
a crate-filled room but after that
you've seen all the crate-filled rooms
unfortunately the technology at the time
made it difficult for bioware to create
multiple truly unique planets but casey
hudson and his team did manage to pull
off the combat
the original pitch for commander
shepherd had then be similar to a jack
bauer or
james bond figure one who would do
anything they needed to
and get away with it to get the job done
to get that feeling across players were
able to combine firearms with biotic
powers
tech skills and squad abilities in order
to take down enemies
they could experiment with different
weapons armor mods and bullet types to
make
weapons feel like their own this feature
was actually surprisingly in depth but
unfortunately a lot of it was buried
under clunky and
complicated menus in the final game the
combat also evolved quite a bit over the
course of development during one of the
early trailers bioware showed off a
system that like kotor and later dragon
age
would allow players to swap between
squad members in order to carry out
different objectives and find enemy weak
points
instead bioware settled for a squad
command feature that would allow you to
use squadmate's abilities on the fly
and tell them where to go and what to do
despite the heavy focus on action based
combat mass effect was still first and
foremost an rpg
and had the most in-depth leveling
systems of the trilogy
throughout the game you are constantly
collecting new equipment weapons mods
and armor
not just for commander shepard but for
your entire team
in conversations an unobtrusive radial
menu would pop up seconds before you
would respond
you'd pick a response and shepard's
dialogue would cut in seamlessly
the camera would even shift and react to
shepard's movements depending on how
they'd respond
in different situations giving it more
of a cinematic feel
and speaking of cinematic bioware added
a ton of film grain and enough lens
flare to
make jj blush mass effect proved to be
an
excellent introduction into a universe
and laid the groundwork for one of the
most ambitious gaming trilogies ever
created
players and critics were quick to point
out its shortcomings but the things that
worked
worked really well bioware had created a
huge universe teeming with stories to
tell and the possibilities
were endless in february 2009 bioware
released a cryptic teaser for mass
effect 2.
it listed some of shepard's achievements
from the first game and it ended with a
line of text saying that he
or she was killed in action the ruse
didn't last all that long as at e3
in june of that year bioware showed off
that yes shepard was still alive
in their ambitious sequel and i don't
use the word ambitious
lightly throughout mass effect you made
many decisions
some that impacted who lived or died in
that game
and others whose ramifications weren't
yet known
characters that had died for some
players were entirely written out in two
and the decisions you made in the first
game had rippling effects on the state
of the galaxy
mass effect 2 truly felt like an
experience that had been molded by the
player but it's hard to talk about the
sequel
without acknowledging its change in
direction
exploration was toned down as was the
deep weapon and power customization
players could pick and choose which
assignments they'd tackle but the levels
themselves were fairly linear
the maker was cut altogether with a
floating vehicle called the hammerhead
being added in a later dlc mission
mass effect 2 was a much more focused
and refined version of a series players
were quickly falling in love with
with 12 squad mates after dlc there was
no shortage of personality aboard the
normandy
morden was a cold but eccentric solarian
scientist
thane adrel assassin coming to terms
with his own impending death
and grunt a krogan bred for war those
were just a few of them each character
had a fleshed-out backstory and loyalty
missions to strengthen your bond with
them
these missions were optional but i'd go
as far as to say that bioware told some
of its finest stories through these side
quests
no no no you always had a plan masked
lifesigns or
or an onboard medical stasis program
maybe
you you wouldn't they're wrong
you wouldn't just die like this one of
the most startling things about mass
effect 2
was just how much darker its tone was
than its predecessors
human colonies were being abducted by
the thousands new squad mates like jack
and thane were cold-blooded killers
and shepherd had defected to a human
extremist group called cerberus
the dominating blue hues were replaced
with reds and oranges
and you would spend the game building up
to this epic conclusion
the infamous suicide mission there it is
the collector base
mass effect 2 was an enormous success a
critical darling and recipient of
numerous awards including the bafta for
best game
it quickly earned spots on lists of best
games of all time and fans absolutely
adored it
the pressure for the third part of the
trilogy was immense
could mass effect 3 marry the two very
different tones of me1 and 2 together
as well as make good on the countless
decisions players had made along the way
to create a conclusion and sequel
befitting of both
the answer to that is in some cases yes
but in other cases no mass effect 3 was
still very much an action game but it
did mark the return
for some of the series early rpg
elements the leveling system was much
more in-depth than twos and weapon and
character customization were taken to
further lengths
it was still a little light on
exploration but with the impending
threat of the reapers coming to destroy
the galaxy
would there really be that much time for
exploring probably not
so instead bioware took another crack at
the combat
and managed to squeeze in the last
puzzle piece that was always missing
melee attacks for the first time in this
series combat just kind of came together
and worked beautifully it didn't feel
janky like mass effect 1 and felt more
cohesive than mass effect 2
it emphasized combos let you grab
enemies from behind cover and added new
powers
the place it really shone was in the
game's pve multiplayer mode which is
still
actually active today the combat was the
best it had ever been and narratively
all the dominoes that had been set up
over the course of six years
were finally starting to fall decisions
came full circle like the raknai queen
on novaria and captain kirahi's fate on
vermeyer
players had vastly different experiences
with mass effect 3
all based on big and little decisions
they had made in one and two
throughout the game it provided payoff
after payoff and
huge emotional beats that is
until it didn't to say expectations for
mass effect 3's ending were high
is an understatement but the endings
players got weren't quite what fans were
hoping for
all your decisions over the course of
three games boiled down to
three endings blue red green
control destroy synthesis respectively
players were quick to point out numerous
plot holes and that a lot of your
decisions ended up feeling
inconsequential this didn't sit well
with fans and they were vocal
it didn't stop with the youtube comments
and threatening tweets seen within the
first few days of mass effect 3's
release either
a petition popped up online demanding
bioware fix the ending
sadly developers were even getting death
threats the team
was crushed after 10 years of
development fans swore off the series
altogether
just because of the last two hours but
it didn't take too long for bioware to
spring into action
to set things straight a few months
after release bioware gave fans an
extended cut of the ending that covered
up some plot holes
added an extra ending and added a little
bit more meat to the original three
however just talking about how the game
ended doesn't do mass effect 3
justice the ending may not have taken
into account your previous choices but
the entire game did
missions would vary depending on how you
chose to play either paragon or renegade
characters will be absent in some
playthroughs and relationships were
dramatically different
and now that the wounds about the ending
have mostly healed it's easy to see how
impressive the mass effect trilogy is
hudson and bioware's high ambitions were
met and after the beloved citadel dlc
the studio took a well-deserved break
from the franchise
at e3 2014 bioware teased another mass
effect game before fully revealing it
the following year
the initial trailer was short on details
other than it would be taking players to
a new galaxy
and that there'd be jetpacks i remember
everyone being very excited about the
jetpacks
mass effect andromeda marked a huge
departure from the original trilogy in a
number of ways not just because it took
place
in a new galaxy it was made by a new
team in montreal rather than edmonton
it used a new engine ea's frostbite
which was a struggle for the team to get
to grips with
mass effect's infamous paragon and
renegade morality system was removed
completely
and there was much more of an emphasis
on exploration than ever before
and of course there was no shepherd in
andromeda you'd play as one of the rider
twins
a pathfinder who was responsible for
finding golden worlds
for milky way civilizations to settle in
the andromeda galaxy
add a new ship the tempest a new vehicle
new squad mates powers enemies and it
all amounted to a huge
change and the reception was mixed
development was turbulent to say the
least
according to a report from jason
schreyer early production had the game
down as more of a no man's sky type
adventure
with the pathfinder and their crew
landing on potentially infinite
procedurally generated worlds
the team couldn't figure out how to
implement a bioware calibre story in a
game with so many shifting parts
so it was canned a new engine brought
about its own issues and frostbite was
actually lacking a lot of key features
that bioware needed
to create rpgs bioware had managed to
get it to work for dragon age
inquisition but they had a hell of a
time doing it
according to schreyer's article bioware
developers said that at that time
an animation system was a key thing that
frostbite didn't have
which is why andromeda's animation was
a little strange to whom and your
goddamn father
sorry my face is tired from dealing with
everything
but andromeda's combat was where it's
shone it was more similar to mass effect
3's multiplayer and while it paired back
issuing commands to your squad mates
it was frenetic with rider constantly
dashing and leaping around the
battlefield instead of cowering behind
waist-high crates
no shade to command a shepherd there it
was way heavier on rpg elements and the
exploration was way more interesting
than mass effect ones
the nomad vehicle was a blast to drive
partly because the need for speed team
assisted in developing it
andromeda's reception was lukewarm
though players didn't connect with
ryder's story or squad mates with the
same intensity as they did with shepard
its sales weren't particularly strong
either bioware quickly began to address
feedback and fix the game's numerous
bugs and animation glitches
but the single player dlc for the game
ended up being cancelled people were
definitely soured on mass effect at that
point
but luckily the series wasn't going to
end on that disappointing feeling
on n7 day 2020 the mass effect legendary
edition was officially revealed
a 4k remaster of the original trilogy
complete with all dlc
except for pinnacle station which was
sadly corrupted and a modernized control
scheme
and then a few weeks later at the game
awards the future of the franchise was
revealed the next
mass effect its trailer featured nods to
both andromeda and the original trilogy
it showed two galaxies the milky way and
andromeda
a dead reaper and a look at fan favorite
liara who was uncovering some
n7 armor right now the theories believe
that it will somehow be a sequel to both
the original trilogy
and andromeda mass effect is an
important franchise to so
many and while it's had its ups and
downs you can't deny just how high those
highs got
the suicide mission its incredible dlcs
in the form of citadel and lair of the
shadow broker
and dozens of hours spent with
characters who feel like friends
is something that most fans will never
forget its lows have been disappointing
but i'm so relieved that the series will
continue
in some form while celebrating and
remastering its past
for new fans to enjoy and i don't know
about you
but it just feels really great to be
excited about mass effect again
thank you so much for watching this is
an updated version of a video that jake
decker made a few years ago but
obviously
with the remaster and a brand new game
it felt like now was definitely the time
to remake this video so i hope you
enjoyed
shout out to jake for all his incredible
work on the original version
if you are into mass effect and i'm sure
you are if you've made it this far
make sure to like this video and
subscribe to the channel because we have
a lot
of mass effect stuff in the pipeline
that you'll definitely enjoy
i'm over on twitter at lucy james games
and i should go
[Music]
you